[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
one two three I agree why why why cuz oh
my Penn State loves by photo so I happy
yes hate my feet yeah yeah we all like
to take them one two three whooping in
me hunt me three more
oh honey take it come on what's one
enjoy me that's one of our enemies and
you know they make a [ __ ] I do
team boo boo Gandhi one two three
ever since I was little I used to play
games with my with my friends I guess
even now I play games with members every
time rule together we play Mario game
yeah because I know I know you play
computer games and you play on you and
switches well you play on your phone
yeah a lot of games so what's your
favorite these days hmm since we're
going around a lot since we move around
a lot I'd say sweet but I think everyone
here in Straker's those playing games
and person who's the most blessed that
game not just because he moves like but
he has a lot of things to do when you
prepare like this promotion any shout
the latest one two three I guess because
we do make most about music so using me
and Chunkin and hunt yeah sorry they
reach we must make most about music yeah
oh my god there's your playing game
here's a mum a lot
and if he's always busy uploading on
your social media yeah okay three one
two three
in my eyes you can just tell I'm just
just by looking at his I think that's
the input today we had so much fun I
like
[Music]